all right the national football league
as expected we'll be taking a closer
look at the incident that happened last
week involving ezekiel elliott he was a
music festival in las vegas there was
one moment in a video that came out uh
tmz as they always do had the video
elliot kind of in the face of a security
guard the security guard getting backed
up against defense the security guard
falling down look this is the kind of
thing that for a player who has never
been in trouble with the nfl before
would i think have no issues no worries
no problems but because elliott has that
six game suspension from 2017 he's a
repeat offender in the eyes of the nfl
they're going to look into it we'll see
what they do i think the nfl is going to
tread more lightly now than they did two
years ago i think there's been a shift
in how aggressively the nfl pursues guys
who haven't been arrested or charged and
elliot facing no arrests no charge no no
legal entanglement at all from the
criminal or civil justice system as a
result of what happened last week but
because it's ezekiel and because of what
happened two years ago charles robinson
of yahoo reports the nfl is likely to
look into it i don't know what they'll
do with it but i'm not surprised at all
chris that they're going to look into it
no not surprised either i mean it's
ezekiel elliott i mean he's one of the
best running backs in football like you
said he's got prior history so
i i understand that as well now listen
there was some
discrepancies and how the nfl went about
getting ezekiel elliott suspended the
the six games two years ago anyways
there was issues there so i do think we
have to note that and did it look a
little unfair in some areas as far as
that investigation yes but okay we're
not going to go there right now at the
very least right here i just go you know
what are you going to really get ezekiel
elliott in trouble for we going to
suspend him football games or chest
bumping a security guard is that where
we're going to go now i mean uh so i
don't under i don't understand that stop
okay
stop stop right there stop right there
a security guard is an authority figure
right you're at an event security guard
is there for security you're getting in
that person's face you're a chest bump a
little chicken wing put him down on the
ground the personal conduct policy
prohibits actual or threatened violence
against anyone it doesn't have to be
domestic violence it doesn't have to be
only a female and i know that the nfl
has been very very vigilant as they
should be about violence committed
against women but if it's a security
guard no matter how big or small if you
are engaging in that kind of activity
you are potentially running afoul of the
personal conduct policy yeah and i agree
with you what happened two years ago
sketchy right questionable
but as far as the nfl is concerned six
game suspension he's a repeat offender
we're not going to relitigate what
happened two years ago in order to
determine whether or not elliot is in
position to have enhanced penalties
that's the key because it's a repeat
offender he gets enhanced penalties what
happens to him is going to be much worse
than what happened to somebody who's got
no prior record as far as the nfl is
concerned so that's why that's why this
becomes something that we need to at
least pay attention to whatever the nfl
does we need to pay attention to it
because of the history i i get you there
and yes i mean i know they have to and i
understand the security guard is an
authority uh you know figure and all
those things i get it uh i guess this is
what bothers me mike that the nfl comes
out and makes comments about this case
quicker and acknowledges the more uh
publicly quicker than they did the tyree
killed vid you know audio tape that's
where i just don't understand the nfl
right now we're gonna address you know
the video of a guy chest bumping a
security offer but we're not gonna make
a comment for a month about the guy
threatening you know his fiancee who has
a domestic abuse of violence that's
where i just don't understand the nfl
sometimes they make a comment real
quickly on this thing and then that one
got swept under the rug for a number of
days
let's be clear the nfl hasn't made a
comment on ezekiel elliott they've sent
multiple emails and they haven't
responded to them this is a report that
that the league is likely to look at it
from an external media company okay i'm
wrong this isn't the nfl coming out and
saying we're going to do this and you
know what
last week the only reason that the nfl
said anything about tyreek hill the
commissioner was asked about it last
week at a press conference that happened
at the end of the ownership meeting the
typical may ownership meeting the
commissioner makes himself available
and uh if somebody asked about ezekiel
elliott he would have had to deal with
it then but nobody asked about ezekiel i
jumped the gun i'm sorry nfl i'm sorry
nfl i jumped the gun there
but still i i agree with you i i think
there should be a greater degree of
transparency if they are looking into
these things and a lot of times they
will say the matter is under review i
don't know why they they have declined
to acknowledge what i think is fairly
obvious it should be under review
because of elliot's history
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports